since we last saw you emma stone on the
show
uh you went and won an oscar well done
you
[Applause]
and there's you know often people in
their special you know i never dreamt of
this moment
but you did more than dream of this
moment i mean you
planned this it wasn't that specific
for that movie to be fair no
i mean what you mean just like in terms
of my childhood
yes when you dreamed when you made your
pitch to your parents yes
i've this is the story will never die
well but i know how old how old are you
when you did it because it was amazing
i was 14 i was almost 15 and i made a
a powerpoint presentation for my parents
but this was so you wanted to move to
l.a
and they didn't want you to go they
weren't going to let you move is that it
well no they did they hadn't even heard
the idea yet
it was just like i realized if i'm gonna
you know i we lived about a six hour
drive from
from la in phoenix arizona and i
realized i couldn't just
come home in my freshman year of high
school which is what grade nine
ninth grade yes okay
and i realized i couldn't just walk in
and go like i'm moving
i'm 14 and here i go so i um decided to
make a powerpoint presentation
about why it would be a good idea for me
to move to
los angeles and follow my big dreams but
you went for it like it had music and
everything yeah it had this song
hollywood by mcdonald
were you in a sensible pants i should
have been in a sensible camp too i think
i was in my
like high school i went to an all-girls
catholic high school so i think i was in
like a plaid skirt and a
collared shirt and so so madonna playing
madonna's playing and then what you just
had a series of reasons why you should
go a series of reasons why this would be
a good idea
not just at any time but now um
and for some reason it did eventually it
worked
and i would punish my child if they had
done that but they believed in me
those freaks but it is true that the
presentation ended with
with the let me go oh didn't it end with
um
you probably remember more about it than
i did well jessica doesn't end it ends
with you putting up the picture and
then it says emma stone actress best
was it best no no didn't it told you
that
first of all my name is emily so there's
no way that emma okay
and then no you didn't say you were
going to win an oscar
why are we telling this story
why are we telling this story what is
the point from this story
that's what i do i thought the whole
point of this is crazy
i don't well it's quite crazy anyway
but that would have made it like
absolutely she's going somewhere
and it's not there because everyone
loves you together in la la land but
this this isn't the first time you've
worked together you worked a
gangster squad and then crazy but love
we've even seen you dance together
before
interesting pose on me i've noticed
you're shirtless
[Laughter]
so double whammy because but now what
happened because the dancing didn't go
to plan in crazy stupid love
uh no oh yeah give me the dirty dancing
lift that's what i mean
yeah well we were meant to do that and
then
what happened oh you don't remember well
i remember but i'd like to hear you
do your version of it listen when i was
when i was about seven years old quick
story
when i was about seven years old i was
in gymnastics class
and i was on these parallel bars that
are about six feet off the ground
and i was standing on the top of the
bars and the teacher was holding me by
the ankles
and somehow or other she let go
and i was standing on this bar and i
felt myself beginning to tip forward
and i put my arms in like this and i
fell six feet
to the ground and i broke both my arms
at the same time
wow and yeah and so uh i
so i you know i spent a whole summer i
lived in arizona which is like 120
degrees which i don't know what that is
in celsius
so i had a cast and all that you know i
was just it was miserable um
it was the day before the last day of
school anyway i had internalized this
again
that's really important
i really know how to tell a story
anyway years later
we do crazy stupid love i know that
we're gonna do the dirty dancing lift i
don't know however that i have an
internalized phobia
of being you know lifted over someone's
head at the height of about six feet
so i run to do the left and ryan lifts
me over his head and i
what did i do ryan i've never had this
happen but i imagine
if a possum fell out of a tree instead
of
trying to scratch your eyes
it would be something similar
it was a lot and then it was like a full
meltdown i mean i had like a real
meltdown
yeah you had to go you crawled in bed
and watched
this is so stupid and then ryan came in
i was like yeah right and then the
directors came in and we're like
yeah right we're going to use the devil
and i was like great
by the way jennifer connolly has a
revelation in this
when you talk about camera it just
sounds like a litany of disasters
that's what it feels like to do cameras
um no it was just i was i was sick for i
would say the majority of the
run and then wasn't there a weird thing
with your contact lenses what happened
oh both of my so i'm um i'm also
just i have the worst eyesight of any
person i've ever met not to brag
very bad and i've only ever lost one
contact lens at a time
uh but on one particular night singing
maybe this time
i blinked and both of them came out
at the same time and i i literally
cannot see and so in the blackout i was
just screaming bill who was our mutual
co-star
i was like bail bill
it had to drag me off in the dark
because i just didn't know how to get
off stage
has anyone ever tried to course it on
have you
worked oh yeah sure yeah yeah
um we've done a lot of course at work
yeah i have actually
he's got an extensive course of training
on many corset roles yeah
yeah quite a few yeah first guy ever who
made a corset
i did a production of twelfth night with
mark rylance and i was playing viola and
mark was playing olivia
and the guy who made the corsets was
called luca and he was amazing and he
he made these corsets it was as if it
was from the 16th century whale bone and
he tightened me into it and
and he had worn corsets all his life and
basically his body went into this
extraordinary kind of
thing
[Laughter]
i don't know the answer to that question
but
there was a horrible moment when he when
when he was i was like oh i'm not going
to eat much when i
when i wear my kills and he went i never
eat
[Laughter]
so i have had some sympathy for the
actresses
no you get it was it was um can you see
it can you see i'm supposed to ask you
did you do the leading
i didn't have a leaning board but i
would i would just like a couch like
this i would because you
cannot sit down you really can't and
it's and honestly like
women existed in that for such a long
time which does give you a lot of
sympathy for that time period what you
were going through but for the first
month
i couldn't breathe and so i would just
smell and sandy powell is the costume
designer she's
fantastic the costumes are beautiful
there's just this one part it's
historically accurate but
i couldn't i would i would smell menthol
and it sort of made me think that i was
in like a wide open space
so i'd just smell a little bit of
menthol and be in a wide open space for
30 seconds
and then be back to not breathing but
then after about a month
um my organs shifted oh my god because
they
have to like what you're saying his
whole body shape changed and it was only
temporary
but um it was gross it was gross do you
feel they've gone back
they've gone back okay they've gone back
for sure
you said that like we knew what happens
when you're do you hear it oh basically
is it like
oh that goes like you're a creaking
sound then there's a pop
and that's
bottom half of my stomach whatever's i'm
not a doctor whatever's in there
went down that way and then i guess just
my ribs stayed up
wow so what anyway don't do it
if you yeah if you don't have to don't
do it but i was
grateful grateful i just want like i
love doing this my lungs in my arms
just stays here's the thing
uh emma for you what is the hold that
the spice girls have
over you is this real yes it's real
and i just feel like i've been talking
more about the spice girls on this press
tour than i have about the movie
i did australia i know i wept did you
really weep i really did
but now which one was talking to you
melby and was she really talking to you
was it a message no it was a video
message on an
ipad and that made you cry yes
were you jet lagged yeah but i also
you don't under i mean you do understand
because we're in the uk yeah i was
i was a fiend i was obsessed with the
spice girls
and they taught me about girl power and
i
love them i think they're fantastic and
i'm what's the song
there's so many jamie there's so many
hey there's so many and they're so
fantastic and today on the radio
um mel c talked to me over skype oh oh
so it's really very exciting okay who
would you say is your favorite spice
girl emma bunton baby spice
she's your favorite she's my favorite
who's next
to that just a question all of the other
four
so emma bunton well emma buntin was the
one that i had blonde hair and bangs and
my name obviously is
now emma my name was emily but it was
taken
when i became an actor um and so
now it's emma and uh yeah i just i
i love so give me this so you one gave
you a video message and one talk to you
on skype yes
what are you telling me you've never met
are you going to are you going to do
something
have you never submitted are you going
to do something really have you never
met a spice girl um
wait hold on i have to mentally prepare
myself
have you never met a spice girl not in
the flesh
okay now as you know as you know
as you know emma it is very rare it is
very rare for more than one spice girl
to appear together
[Applause]
for any reason at all
[Music]
so they're not here
you